for theater chains 2020 started out with
a bang
the opening weekend for bad boys for
life starring will smith
raked in more than 73 million dollars
many of those tickets were sold at amc
theaters
the year before the world's largest
theater chain took in nearly five and a
half
billion dollars and was poised for
another strong showing in 2020
but the coronavirus pandemic quickly
made going to the movies a public health
risk
and in mid-march amc closed all of its
roughly 630 u.s locations
but the chronovirus pandemic isn't the
only thing pushing the company onto
financially shaky ground
here's how amc went from king of the
silver screen to
trying to avoid bankruptcy
the first movie theaters opened around
the turn of the 20th century
and by 1916 there were more than 21 000
movie theaters in the u.s most were
nickelodeons
named after the admission price of one
nickel in 1920
the dubinsky family purchased a theater
in kansas city missouri
their company would later be renamed
american multi-cinema
or amc amc introduced the world's first
multiplex in the early 60s
and 10 years later the company owned 183
theaters in 13 states
soon after amc was molding the
moviegoing experience into what it is
today
attendance rose in movie theaters in the
us
as hollywood sort of improved its
ability to build these blockbusters that
were rich in spectacle
special effects uh amc played a big role
uh as it was building prominent
multiplexes in the 1980s amc was also
the first theater to install cupholders
and the armrests
and they also promoted the ramped up
stadium seating that's sort of
ubiquitous today
but then throughout time you had other
introductions of technological
advancements like the vcr
and you had cable television like hbo
because of these new at-home options
sumner redstone who owned rival theater
chain national amusements
said he planned to put a halt on
building new theaters
not amc by the end of the decade it had
more than 290 locations
but still only around 1700 of the us's
23 000 total movie screens in the 90s
the company rushed to build megaplexes
with 16 or more auditoriums
faster than any other chain by the end
of the decade
it had 2700 screens about half of them
in megaplexes
but that building boom put the entire
theater industry into debt
to the tune of more than five billion
dollars
two years later amc strengthened its
balance sheet by selling a quarter
billion dollars of stock
to the private equity firm apollo
management which effectively took
control of the company
the new investors got in just as the
industry was hitting its peak
of nearly 1.6 billion theater admissions
a year
this marked the beginning of an era of
rapid acquisition for the movie chain
in 2005 amc merged with rival lowe's
theaters
the roughly four billion dollar deal
created a 5
900 screen theater empire then seven
years later
china's richest man at the time wang
zhan lin put amc
on course to become the biggest movie
theater chain in the world
he bought the company for around 2.6
billion dollars
that included nearly 2 billion dollars
in debt but movie studios were beginning
to make bigger demands for theaters to
screen blockbuster films
in 2013 before the release of iron man 3
amc and rival regal theaters refused to
sell online tickets to disney's highly
anticipated movie
typically studios and movie theaters
will split ticket revenue 50 50.
studios make the movie they market the
movie theaters show the movie
amc and regal said disney wanted too
much of a cut
the three companies eventually reached a
compromise but the standoff
showed a shift in the power dynamics
around hit movies
this model of creating big event style
movies um and fewer movies has become
the model
um that is most successful so you're
seeing these huge big blockbusters like
an avengers movie
and as more emphasis have been put on
fewer movies
that in turn has given studios more
leverage
despite fewer movies driving ticket
sales the theater giant kept on growing
in 2016 amc acquired both u.s based
carmic cinemas
and europe's odeon and uci cinemas group
making it the world's
largest movie theater company but by
then movie attendance numbers had
flattened
exposing a major liability for the
industry
too many theaters and not enough people
to fill them
you had old theaters so you needed newer
theaters that were nicer to compete
against those older theaters but at the
same time you had all these better
options at home the bigger tvs
streaming and dvd and whatnot to keep
pace
theater chains raised ticket prices but
also upgraded their amenities to draw
viewers out of the home
they're trying to make the experience
more luxurious with lazy boy chairs
offering better food options anything
they can
to sort of offset and convince people
hey it's worth paying this extra one or
two dollars a ticket
this business model worked as long as
there were hit movies to sell
tickets in 2017 revenues climbed with
the help of such hits as finding dory
and rogue one a star wars story but the
next year
lackluster box office performance led to
declining revenues
and amc's share price plummeted add to
that
another shot across the bow from disney
it required theaters to commit to giving
the studio a record high 65 percent of
ticket revenues
to screen star wars the last jedi these
big movies like a star wars avengers
these movies are make or break for
theaters they need those
movies in order to have a good year
in 2019 amc screened marvel's avengers
in-game
a record 58 000 times over its opening
weekend
then in 2020 disaster struck the entire
industry with the coronavirus pandemic
in march amc announced it was closing
all of its theaters worldwide
it happened at a time when the company
was loaded with nearly
5 billion dollars in debt causing the
ceo
to sound the alarm there are no revenues
coming in the door but we're going to
have to get liquidity from some place
if we all in our industry if we all have
expenses
and none of us have revenues a lot of
people believe that the market was
oversupply that there's too many screens
too many theaters in the us
and i've spoken to a lot of people and
they predict as many as half of theaters
in the u.s and canada
could go out of business forever after
the end of the pandemic
amc is thrilled to welcome you back to
the movies with our new amc
safe and clean initiative for now amc
has buoyed itself by reopening over
80 percent of its locations although
with social distancing guidelines
and without many marquee movies and its
stock price
spiked following the announcement of an
effective coronavirus vaccine candidate
but it was still far removed from its
highs five years ago
right now the company is burning through
100 million dollars a month
and faces the possibility of running out
of cash by year's end
studios fear uh that people will just
become increasingly more accustomed to
watching movies at home
and when the pandemic's over instead of
it bouncing back to normal
maybe even the frequent moviegoers
instead of going six or seven times a
year they're only going two or three
times a year
the ceo recently told investors the
company was prioritizing
raising cash and reducing costs but at
least for now
there doesn't seem to be much of a
silver lining for the silver screen
giant